So, this is the state of the processor. We have some instructions fetched.
This is the very first one that we will be trying to issue.
This is our reservation stations, our register file with the values,
the RAT that says where the values are currently and
it's pointing to the register file for now. The ROB that is empty for now.
This is a little table that we will be writing what happens in which cycle. And
then, this is kind of the legend for our reservation stations and
ROBs because we need to know, which field to put which value in. So in cycle 1,
what's going to happen is, we're going to try to issue this first instruction.
To do that, we need. An available reservation station and
an available ROB entry, we have both, so we are ready to go. It's a divide, and
we're going to write the divides kind of operation here. It's writing to R2,
so we're going to note that in the destination register over here.
We're going to write the destination tag in the reservation station, that's
going to be ROB1 now. Remember that. The value we broadcast the result with,
basically the tag that everybody's trying to compare, is now going to be the ROB
entry number, not the reservation station number. That's what allows us to free
reservation stations very quickly. The R3 and R4 are going to be looked up here.
We will find that it's 45 and 5, and write it here. And then,
we are going to rename R2, so that it points to ROB1 from now on. And
then because we said that we will be able dispatch in the very same cycle and
begin execution in the next cycle, we have issued this instruction Cycle 1.
It's going to begin executing in Cycle 2 because both of its operands have
values ready to go. Now in Cycle 2 this instruction begins executing, so
the reservation station becomes free. Before I free the reservation station I'm
going to note that this instruction is dividing 45 and 5,
so the result that is going to eventually end up in ROB is going to be 9,
45 over 5. This instruction is not done so
technically this value lands here only when it's done but I'm going to note this
is what's going to happen because, I want to know what that value will be. And,
with that, this reservation station becomes free. So now what's going to happen,
this is a divide. It's going to take 40 cycles to do things so in cycle 42,
which is the 41st cycle since we began executing. We tried to write its result.
That's going to be a long time in the future. Meanwhile, in Cycle 2 we're
going to try to do, the rest of the things. Can we dispatch something else,
well nothing to dispatch? Can we issue something. Well the multiplication has
a reservation station and ROB entry ready to be obtained, so we can do that.
It's a MUL of R1. The tag for it is now going to be ROB2. R5 and R6, are 3 and
4. So we have the values, we don't have to wait for
anything. And R1 is a result. Now we need to remember that
R1 from now on is mapped to ROB2. Basically, if anybody from now on wants to ru,
use R1, it really needs to wait for the result of instruction in ROB2.
So this instruction has issued in Cycle 2. It's gone up this batch,
also in Cycle 2 because it's ready to go. So in Cycle 3,
it's going to begin executing. And, with that, we have moved to cycle 3.